like I think it's uh you know I do
definitely feel like less like you know
I think I have enough self-awareness to
feel to see the spots in my life that I
have been very lucky in as opposed to
some things I've like worked more
towards
um I feel very very blessed that I have
found like a partner because one thing
that [__] that has like always been
like
so like something outside of my
uh let me rephrase that something that I
could never see myself going through
is just the adult dating world right
because I've okay so I obviously you
know no rizz no rizz
I was lucky I was lucky enough to meet
Sydney at a time of my life before I
entered like the whole professional kind
of dating world yeah uh
I'm correct what I mean by that is well
when you are a [__] working adult and
you have to manage your time and your
love life yeah uh for me like I managed
to meet like all my you know previous
Partners through kind of like more let's
say not not natural but more Hobbies
yeah it it wasn't like uh when you
didn't have a nine to five yeah when I
didn't have a nine to five it felt more
uh there's a word that I'm that's better
organic organic that's it yeah and in a
more organic way than just going on an
app and being like we are going to meet
for a date at this time and see if we're
romantically interested in each other
you know I've never had a meaningful
connection from anyone I've met like
Tinder anything right yeah because you
just never I don't know why I think I
just went into it I was like oh it's
just tendering it I was never like
considered it like that I don't know I I
I mean that's saying that was probably
going in my brain where I was like this
is just not I just don't see this as
serious yeah yeah I mean I I doubt the
majority of people who use that website
do take it serious to be honest I mean
you know there are some instances
I have a friend from high school who met
his girlfriend on Tinder and now I
certainly believe you can and you know
Tinder loves to [__] use that story
whenever they can yeah yeah this could
be you yeah but you know and then you I
never I never everywhere near those
[__] some people on like this really
serious dating websites where it's like
you would have to enter like a 900 part
survey and answer how like this yeah and
stuff and you're you're awesome
websites it's like that that's I don't
know to me that's like that's too much
I'm like that's like now you're trying
to gamify something that can't be
gamified right yeah like there is no x
equals y here it's like you just you
kind of vibe with someone just figure it
out man I'm farming love points right
now but that also comes back to like a
societal pressure of like we're always
taught you have to be in a relationship
yada yada you have to get with someone
it's like I don't know who [__] cares
yeah and it's like you know that's tough
though because sometimes people even
when they know they shouldn't be they
feel societal pressure they just do and
it's impossible for them to somehow get
out of that
is there a difference between a need to
finding like a partner and horniness
like okay okay break down that question
is there a difference between wanting to
find like a partner for life like
marriage yeah kids and family or just
like a one night stand okay
okay so this survey that Phil said right
it was like uh more men feel single and
lonely it's not just lonely it's single
and right right so are they uh dude what
does that mean does that mean that they
uh it means they have no risk it doesn't
mean that they need more frizz or does
that mean that they are missing a
partner in life that's the probably both
I think you can be in a relationship and
be lonely
yes 100 yes
on the flip side I believe you can be in
a relationship and be horny as well
[Laughter]
there is definitely a lot of like
married couples out there that might
have you know lost the flame and uh
literally every Japanese couple that
like uses like a [__] soap land right
like that's literally it they're in a
committed relationship but they still
want to [__] yeah so it's genuinely like
what are what are what are people
looking for nowadays like are they
desperate what are they more desperate
for because I feel I see let's say a lot
of thirsty people pop up in my timeline
you know every every now and again we we
see it we're now we're now getting into
a topic of hammer you know is the access
of porn is it harmful like is having too
much damaging the youth I guess a lot of
the times I'm you know I I think if
anyone anyone interests me like Pawn
should be banned I'm like shut the [__]
up [__] but it's like I think there's a
legitimate thing of like is consumed
doing far too much porn does it do
something yeah there's a limit like yeah
yeah you know for sure it's it's just
like it's like a [__] coffee it's
like yeah you can you can abuse coffee
yeah like I think but I don't think yeah
you're looking the guy that does it yeah
but I think like people who would be
like we should ban coffee it can be
dangerous like shut the [__] up yeah
don't [__] get a [__] grip
shut up you know just don't be horny
don't be horny going back to what you
said about loneliness and horniness yeah
I think what that meant was like people
who were single and loneliest and like
maybe they didn't have any meaningful
connections and they were also single
yeah right not not that they were horny
and sing what okay okay okay what did
you asking because I think
they were getting no [__] in every
sense of the word so you can you can
like okay gonna go okay so um let's say
you all that's this is so stupid okay
let's oh we're here let's discuss let's
say you uh you're one of those guys that
identified yourself as single one lonely
okay what were what were you more
desperate to look for to what what void
were you trying to fill were you trying
to fill the horny void or were you
trying to fill the connection voids well
I think which is what a lot of people I
mistakenly assume that you fill both
with the same thing
Phil yeah
well that's the thing I feel maybe for a
lot of those people loneliness can
equate to either one or both yeah you
know I'm sure there are some people who
are just like I don't really have
interest in like you know finding a
partner or or a wife and a husband and
you know starting a family or anything I
just want someone who's there for me uh
to you know you know maybe fulfill my
sexual you know frustrations or you know
like maybe lack thereof any kind of
human Connection in that sense yeah and
then I'm sure there are some people who
are like yeah I'm kind of done sleeping
around I just want to find someone that
I can just love for the rest of my life
and start a family with right yeah
because like I you know in in my life I
have known like a few Lads a few guys as
well who you know they would uh their
top priority wasn't so much finding a
let's say a real like
relationship or like a like a partner
they just wanted to find someone anyone
you know and it and no no it's like like
just some like a partner just to like
feel that void of not having a partner
there yeah and it was less of like is
there a real connection there and it's
more of okay this is a partner who I can
you know I can obviously sleep with
because we're we're in a relationship
um but also they're kind of just there I
kind of just want that void to be filled
and that was more like just having
someone there was more important than
finding the right person or the right or
or in Japan
no I think it just means just present
just somebody who's just oh someone's
just in there in your life yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I've met like several
people like that in their life who if
they're not in a relationship or even if
you know especially someone who has just
not been in a relationship period
they're just kind of looking for anyone
to fill that hole you know well I mean
again like that's the whole reason why I
like soap lands in Japan are so [__]
popular and because like people Japan
has just figured out oh I need someone
there even for a short period of time to
like you know make sure and reiterate to
myself that oh I'm not lonely and Japan
was like well you can do that just pay
to win bro and then you got it it's all
it's all it's all pay to win
baby there will be there will be someone
there for you whether that be in a soap
land a hostess club a host club any kind
of like [__] Cafe cuddle Cafe
whatever it may be there's so many
different varieties of it now in Japan
and it's like yep here you go it from
from zero horniness to level 100
horniness we have everything on the
Spectrum you can choose it's just pay to
win yeah you know and I've always like
I've always wanted because I you know
was very little kids because you know
when I was growing up I was like I'm not
gonna get married until I'm at least 35
in my mind right in my mind that's what
I thought my life path was going to be
y35 I don't know that just that number
just felt like
what I thought when I thought I would be
ready right you know settle down and
settle down with a life partner in my
mind
um and I you know life doesn't always go
the way you think it's gonna go
um I thought I was going to meet my life
partner way later in life and you know
have way more time before I actually you
know tied the knot but I ended up
meeting Sydney way earlier than when I
thought I would
um and I have you know I found someone
that fills everything I've wanted to in
a partner so
um I that's where I recognize I'm very
blessed so because I didn't have to go
through the you know Tinder phase or
just like the phase where the date game
the date the Day game where I'm working
but also I have to like try to find time
to find love in my life and that's why I
asked the question because because I've
never been through that stage in my life
I'm like what do people look for they
are they more looking for are they
looking for a real human connection or
are they horny do they just want to [__]
are they and they want to [__] which is
totally fair you know I'm a guy as well
I get horny as well I [__] get it you
know it's it's like I it's more of like
a genuine question I think there are the
three of us are the only one who has
experienced
all right
whatever it is that I mean it depends
where you're at in your life really
because like your priorities and what
you're looking for change uh
all the time uh I would just go on dates
because I thought that was what I was
supposed to do yeah I was like oh I
should I just kind of date people that's
right I was you know because like I'm
sure uh there's something in your life
where your parents like oh you seeing
anyone
and it's like that kind of that kind of
conversation yeah right like like like
that is a thing that will always be
asked and like that and it's not even
just Asia I think every every [__]
yeah yeah yeah
Asian mom's like tenfold they're like
yeah are you seeing someone are you
dating anywhere and it's like that that
little question that gets asked all the
time by a lot of people in your life
kind of and you're always yeah you're
always ask this in your life kind of
cements this idea for a lot of people
that you have to be with someone you
should be dating you should be looking
and so I I think there was never a point
I think in my entire adult life there's
always a point where I was either you
know uh dating uh just looking I guess I
don't know what the [__] but messing
around
um or in a relationship there's always a
point where I was doing one of those
just I thought that was what I was
supposed to do yeah yeah like I was like
oh yeah this is what I do and I think I
would never question why I was doing it
or what I was looking for so and you
know sometimes you'd be in these dates
and be like what do you want I'm like I
[__] know like I'm sure I'm just
trying to make YouTube videos like I'm
not concerned about this like this is
not where I where I'm at right now
they'd be like I want to get married I'm
like well I'm not the guy you know and a
lot of a lot of people a lot of people
have you know they're like yeah like you
they're like I don't get married till
this age and they they change a lot I
was always the camp of like I am I do
not care about getting married and I'm
not getting mad anytime soon and I'd
mean it to them and I I think they would
be like I could change him I'm like I'm
not I could fix him I need to say that
now no I I I'm absolutely not you know
the financial implications of this this
is a nightmare to do like I am not doing
this
I'm her I'm her yeah you know and it's
like like I think why people date is
always different like I think a lot of
people also
you know a lot of guys and there was
definitely a time in my life where I
thought this was the case where it was
always Associated from movies and stuff
growing up that the cool guy was the guy
who got a lot of girls you listed did
around right yeah and I feel like this
this is caused this idea of toxic
masculinity has caused so much more
Fallout and then we can even comprehend
I feel because I realized I caught
myself kind of falling into that trap of
thinking that way yeah and I feel like
I'm a pretty self-aware guy and I'm I
and I was like God this and then you
look online I feel like this is where a
lot of incel kind of like uh rhetoric
has come from this kind of stuff and I
feel like this idea has caused so many
[__] problems
um and you know you've probably met guys
now like you've mentioned to this day
who still have that idea of I should I
should look around I should date as many
girls as possible yeah because that's
cool that's what a cool guy does yeah
double standard right yeah and like it's
like it's it was honestly when I was
dating the most people was probably the
loneliest I was like this is like I'm
forming no connections above like one
day like this is such a no no no let's
not say that like [__] it's like it
would just be like I would just go on a
date a single time maybe nothing
happened a bunch of the time I was like
90 you know and then I would just be
like wow what a [__] waste like I
didn't even try and build a meaningful
connection yeah just meet up with people
one time and never talk to them ever
again yeah sometimes the [__] isn't
worth it it wouldn't even be for like
that right I would just be like I would
just be like I would literally turn up I
would lose an entire day spend a bunch
of money and I would get literally
nothing out of it yeah I was like why am
I doing this to myself like I don't I
and then you know after a while you're
like I just kind of want something I
kind of want to like have something
meaningful yeah yeah of course or you're
just like oh you just like hold up
maybe I just need time for me maybe I
just need to step back from all yes yeah
I think I think a big thing is that a
lot of guys feel like they need you can
certainly not they need to have a
relationship in order to feel let's say
fulfilled or to feel like not lonely you
know and I'm like it's an easy way to
think that if you're lonely that it's
the easy answer I think for a lot of
guys yeah because a lot of the times for
some people it can be but I think for a
lot of dudes like you're saying it's a
super easy thing to go for right away
yeah like this is my loneliness yeah and
then maybe when you you get in the
relationship realize I had a lot more
problems than I I realized I had because
this relationship is not working out
yeah there's a lot of unhealthy things
going on here and I'm I'm woefully I'm
prepared to address these yeah um it's
it's only when you're in a bad
relationship do you realize how good a
good relationship for sure for sure yeah
very very grateful for a lot of my
terrible relationships yeah I've learned
the whole [__] lot same here same
here it's made me appreciate it's a good
thing when it's like presented right in
front of me you know that's that's uh
that's the big